[Music]
let's go to emily in fairview tennessee
what's up emily
hi dr john how are we doing
today's a good day how are you today is
a good day that's a fantastic way to say
that
fairview is one of my favorite places
that's fantastic man so what's up yeah i
like it out here
well um
my husband has been close to suicide
four times in as many months
and my question for you is
how do i find peace
who man
that's a tough one so walk me back um
what happened four months ago that
started this
dominoes
well um
i you know i think it started before
then he's
a military veteran and ptsd
um
pretty sure he's got depression anxiety
um
and we've we've been fighting for a long
time to try to get him some
mental health counseling therapy through
the va
and
took a long time to get that to happen
took him actually driving out to a
bridge
to get that to happen through the va um
and so they've
he's had counseling
for a little while through them but it's
been very inconsistent they'll go like
two months between sessions um
anyway so so
what why
um
we have recently found someone else okay
that is not through the va okay that was
my this is a
this is a level one emergency
yeah and so i'm not waiting on them
anymore
yeah
uh yeah i'm not waiting on them at all
um good for you so we gave up on that
that route good good and i know that
that adds another level of shame and
frustration and anger and rage to a
veteran that the one group that sent him
out now doesn't want to do anything
remotely close to
provide the help and care that he needs
um right that's that's a whole other
level man i'm so sorry
um so
what happened four months ago that
that something so there was some
triggering event that said i'm just
gonna i'm i'm practicing this i'm
leading up to this
i i don't know what the trigger was okay
i don't know
so where is he now
um
you know he's got good days and bad days
but
you know i think he's still in a dark
place and you know he's only started
with this this new therapist you know um
two weeks ago
so
he's still
i feel like he's fighting as a dragon
you know and
he doesn't have any
tools
to fight it with right now he's fighting
with his bare hands gotcha is he there
would he talk to me
uh he's not home right now okay
i'd love it if he called in and if he
calls in we'll move him to the front of
the line okay
okay cool um
man it breaks my heart
um
there's a lot so do you have little ones
yeah we got a six-year-old and a
four-year-old of course you do
um how are they doing how much of this
are they absorbing
um
i don't know
they don't know what's going on um
the night that he drove out to the
bridge when he got back home
and told me what had happened
i i broke down and cried and it was my
six-year-old daughter who was like
patting me on the back and comforting me
and i was you know i i couldn't breathe
but
um
so she you know
they know something's up probably
what kept what's happening
what kept him off kept him on
kept him on yeah
um i don't know
we
the night that happened we were
having a normal
conversation it was a very like
we were talking about hey what day is
this happening what you know when are we
is this on friday or saturday kind of a
very
administrative type conversation
and all sudden he just said
why am i even here and just left
and later he said he wasn't sure why he
was feeling that way
so okay
so
i would tell you
one of the cornerstones of
you've probably heard me say this on the
show but just to reiterate for everybody
listen and if we have new listeners
every cell in the human body has one job
and that's to get to tomorrow
and then to get to the next day and then
get to the next day
and to override the system
and jump off of a bridge or to shoot
yourself or to take your life to die by
suicide
it takes an extraordinary
amount of
resolve
more so than we think
it's just so foreign to every part of
our body
down to the cellular level right
um
and one of the chief suicidologists the
person who studies suicide that i have a
high respect for
suggests that it's such a hard thing to
get your body to do that when they look
back postmortem on people who have died
by suicide
um there is often
a trail of practice attempts
driving out
cutting deeper and deeper being a little
bit more reckless with guns or getting
it out and looking at it and getting out
and holding it
and so what i would tell you is this and
i know that you know this i just want
you to hear me say it um
this is as though your house is on fire
and he's trapped inside and you and your
daughter you and your kids are out in
the front yard that's how serious this
is
okay um
if at all possible there should probably
be some sort of inpatient
the fact that he is seeing somebody
right now is a really great sign
and i would ask if i'm here's what i'm
gonna try to give you some some glimpses
of peace but your home is on fire and so
you're not gonna have peace in this
particular season right now and so i
want you to make peace with not having
peace for a minute okay
often the rage and anger and frustration
and
inability to sleep and move is because
we're expecting things to be still and
they're not
and so
expect things to be choppy right now
kind of like i was just talking about
skiing the other day
whenever a boat drives by and the wake
is coming i expect it to be really
really bumpy and then i can deal with
the bumps it's when i expect to be
smooth and all bump comes out of nowhere
and i eat it does that make sense
yeah okay so expect to be there to be a
limited amount of peace in the next few
however long okay
okay i would ask
if he's okay with it
if for your own
peace of mind if he would sign a release
so that you could call his counselor and
get an update
oh okay
and if he signs a release the therapist
is required to
if you call and say i just need to check
in and see what um what level of concern
you have for my husband's well-being
on a scale of one to ten you come up
with some sort of skill and you can tell
them i don't want to know all the
intimate details i don't want to know
all of the things
i just want to know that you're okay and
i would love for you to sign it would
give me peace in my heart
another thing that would be huge is if
he would do this
if he he would
commit to
no talking
just hand holding or
i'm looking for skin on skin moments
okay
and that may be hard with the kids and
all the crazy you know
can we have some you call them sos
moments you can call them skin on skin
moments
and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna pester you
about where you feeling what do you
think am i gonna do that
that's gonna hold you
i want you to hold me
yeah okay
and what we're trying to do is call is
have your body go
a third thing if i were you
i would go see a counselor too
okay because you're in this too
yeah well i started i started uh seeing
someone through better help good good
for you as well
good for you good for you
um
the majority of people who die by
suicide do not want to be dead
they want their hurt to stop
yeah exactly
yeah and the majority of people who die
by suicide
have some sort of
ramp up to this process and so the fact
that one of the questions i would ask
have you ever tried before yep four
times in as many months
that to me is on top of
combat service on top of like you're
giving me a you're painting a picture of
me of a very volatile individual
okay yeah
yeah
i'm so sorry that you're here and i'll
just tell you he's really really lucky
to have you
well i'm lucky to have him too i know
but it's scary right
yeah
has he made you a promise that he'll
call you
what do you mean
um there's been some some efficacy
concerns around this and what meaning
there's been some studies that say yay
or nay on this
um one thing that i still love
and
it may it doesn't guarantee anything
um
but i would love it if you had a piece
of paper that you wrote and did it nice
and said this is a contract between you
and me
i'm the one woman you said you were
going to be here for
and i want you to promise
that you will never kill yourself
and that if you ever feel like it you
will call me or you will call somebody
okay and make him sign it and you sign
it
now there's some like i said there's
people who've done studies and say that
doesn't really do anything or some
people just sign it and then they go
ahead and do
it's not guaranteeing anything
but here's what it does it gives you and
him an intimate moment that says i'm
asking a covenant of you
to not leave me yes yeah
okay
and that might be a moment filled with
tears it might be a hard moment
um i think you can do all this in a
single conversation and then here's the
last one let me let me throw this one on
there
ask him
let's clear the entire deck
pretend we're meeting for the first time
what do you need from me
yeah okay what can i bring to the table
for you
is it silence is it quiet is it touch is
it
are you just so sick of the gluten-free
bagels that i'm always making like right
like like what what can i bring to the
table do we need to move
do you need to re-enlist like what are
the what do what do we need to do to
come to the table
and let him know i'm all in
um the last last last one is this idea
of perceived burdensomeness
is the idea that
people who die by suicide over time
begin to feel like the world would be
better if i wasn't here
my kids would be better off if i wasn't
here
yeah he's really prone to
shameful thoughts about himself that's
right just guilt yep does do you know of
things that happened overseas
uh yeah okay
that contribute to that
yeah okay
um that's hard that's hard to sit with
and sit and unwind do you have a couple
of veterans in your local community that
you have their numbers so you can reach
out to him that he can reach out to
him yeah he's well he's got a buddy he's
not local but he's got a buddy that he
has reached out to when he was feeling
suicidal before he needs some people in
fairview
okay or in lieber's fork area or in
franklin he needs some people local in
dixon okay
yeah he has he has local friends too but
i don't know that they're veterans
though
he needs some people who've been there
okay okay
and um he may say no and you can tell
them you you may not get them i'm
getting them i'm gonna reach out okay
and i'm gonna make this weird on all of
us
um
and i'd love for him to call if he'd be
willing to okay
okay i know he's fighting uh world war
iii in his in his head right now
and
i'm sorry that's going on for him i'm
sorry that's going on for your two
little ones and i'm sorry that's going
on for you
and if he happens to has a chance to
listen to this i need him to hear me say
the world will not be better off with
you not here
and
carrying the bricks of shame son set him
down
it's time to set him down
the heartbreaking part for you emily is
that he's the only one that can do that
for himself okay
have you made him a promise to never
call or never tell or anything like that
no um
he made me promise to tell
people good hey
gosh that's a brave man that's an
awesome guy
if you ever get a hint call everyone
call 9-1-1 every friend every pastor
everybody you know every time okay
okay promise yourself that okay
maybe when you ask him to sign the
wellness contract
you hand him on and say
anytime i'm calling in everybody
everybody
eat i'm gonna call so many people i'm
gonna call an idiot podcaster that's
what i'm gonna call
right
uh i'm gonna call everybody okay okay
emily we love you and you call anytime
we can help and if you can get him on
the phone with me i would love that too
okay
okay all right you're doing all the
right things and
man
if you are watching this
the world would not be better with you
not in it
and for a moment you think i just need
this to stop
remember this moment i'm sitting with
you
we're all sitting with you
reach out and make that call
reach out and make the call